8 news now learning the three identities
of Tuesday's triple homicide it includes
the maintenance workers sent to the
alleged Killers apartment to perform a
welfare check those closest to him
to him and just a victim of homicide 8
news now reporter Ryan Matthey joins us
live from The Newsroom with new
information surrounding the incident
Ryan yeah Kirsten Brian his name was
Christopher brasser the rancher in
Montana apartment complex is where he
spent much of his days helping others
live comfortably it includes the man who
would eventually take his life those
closest to him describe him as an
extremely good person while the arrest
report for Spencer McDonald describes
the killing much more
I didn't deserve it nobody deserves it
obviously but I mean Zach range
grappling with the loss of this man 45
year old Christopher brassard by the end
of the day there were probably 30 people
at my house mourning him and celebrating
him he shares this photo the first look
at the apartment complex worker who he
says lived with him and his
four-year-old daughter for more than six
years he was a straight Uncle to her she
loved him dearly and it was the same it
goes both ways a man with great advice
great with kids and a great friend range
says he considered brassard a brother
the last time they spoke was hours
before he was killed last time I saw him
we were both taken off to work
every day I love you man I hope you have
a good day I'll see you tonight
please say brassart and another
maintenance worker we're told by
apartment management to perform a
welfare check on this man's apartment
30-year-old Spencer McDonald on Tuesday
a Washington Post article from 2013
where his family was profiled reveals he
suffers from schizophrenia documents the
8 news now investigators obtained
Thursday reveal McDonald admitted to
police that he murdered his 80 year old
grandmother and her 43 year old
boyfriend days prior in a police
interview the surviving maintenance
worker said once inside the apartment
McDonald began attacking both with a
hammer brassard suffered multiple sharp
force injuries according to the Clark
County coroner but that's not how those
closest to the 45 year old man remember
him give you the shirt right off his
back he would do anything for anyone
people like that this world needs a lot
more of that
now the arrest report says McDonald
admitted to killing all three but did
not provide his motive the report also
reveals the 80 year old victim his
grandmother had a friend who first
requested the welfare check but as that
friend was calling police management at
the apartment complex sent brassord and
the other maintenance worker instead
reporting Live From The Newsroom Ryan
Matthey a news now